[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم معكم سهام قشطه ونستعرض معا
ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي بايجاز وفي
نشرتنا صفقه لتبادل السجناء بين ايران
وامريكا الاحتلال يغتال مقاومين بالضفه
وبريطانيا تخري عباره طالبي اللجوء بسبب
بكتيريا واخبار اخرى لنتابعها معا البدايه
من اتفاق واشنطن وطهران على الصفقه لتبادل
اطلاق السجناء والغاء تجميد مليارات
الدولارات من عائله النفط الايراني ويشمل
الاتفاق الافراج عن خمسه سجناء من كل طرف
ونقل اموال طهران المجمده من كوريا
الجنوبيه الى سويسرا قبل ايداعها في
حسابات خاصه في قطر ومن جهاته قال البيت
الابيض للجزيره ان قطر قدمت دعما للتوصل
للاتفاق الذي وصفه بالخطوه الايجابيه
واضاف ان واشنطن ستكون مطلعه على وجهه
الارصده الايرانيه وستفرض قيودا على ما
يمكن فعله بها لكن ما اهميه الصفقه في هذا
الت بعد سنوات من الفشل في الوصول الى اي
اتفاق بين واشنطن وطهران هذا ما سنسال عنه
ضيفنا دكتور محجوب الزويري استاذ الدراسات
الخليج وايران في جامعه قطر مرحبا بك
دكتور محجوب كيف سيستفيد الجانبان من هذه
الصفقه مجرى سهام في غايه الاهميه هناك
تاكيد امريكي ايراني على ان مسار التفاوض
مفتوحا ويجب ان يبقى مفتوحا رغم كل
العقبات ورغم كل الجهود التي تريد الابقاء
على حاله التوتر بالنسبه لايران الحصول
على عوائد ماليه مهمه جدا في وقت العقوبات
الحصول على ادويه مستلزمات طبيه اشياء
ممنوعه وفق العقوبات وبالتالي هذا يساعد
الحكومه الايرانيه بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده واداره بايدن هذا تاكيد على ان
ادارتهم ملتزمه بالاتفاق النووي وانها
جاده في المحافظه عليه وانه يريد لهذا
الاتفاق ان ينجح وهذا نوع من الاشارات على
ذلك
دكتور
محجوب حيث تصاعدت عمليات الاغتيال
الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه اذا استشهد
شاب فلسطيني بر القوات الاحتلال اثر
اقتحامها مخيمه طولكرم بينما شيع
الفلسطينيون جثمان الشهيد المقاوم في
كتائب شهداء الاقصى امير خليفه الذي
اغتالته قوات الاحتلال في كمين غرب نابلس
ياتي ذلك بعد ايام من اغتيال ثلاثه شبان
مقاومين بينهم قائد كتيبه جنين باطلاق
النار على سيارتهم ارتفاع عدد الشهداء
واقتحامات الاحتلال المدن الفلسطينيه زادت
وتيراتها بشكل كبير عن ذلك نسال المختصه
في الشان الاسرائيلي خلدون البرغوثي سيد
خلدون ما الذي يرمي اليه الاحتلال من
تزايد عمليه الاغتيالات والاقتحامات
فالضفه الغربيه من الواضح ان الاحتلال
يلجا في النهايه الى ما يسمى حسم الصراع
التعامل مع الفلسطيني بالنسبه لاسرائيل هو
تعاون امني منذ اللحظه الاولى للاحتلال
ولا تزال تتعامل بهذه الطريقه لذلك كل
الخيارات المطروحه هي خيارات امنيه او
عسكريه كان هناك عمليه قبل
فتره في مخيم جنين ومن الواضح انها فشلت
لذلك سيستمر هذا التعامل ربما بتغيير
التكتيكات اي طبيعه العمليات من العمليات
الواسعه الى العمليات المحدوده السريعه
التي ينفذ بها اغتيال
وعدم تجربه الاجتياحات طويله المدى لان
ذلك يؤذي جنود الاحتلال ويؤذي صوره
اسرائيل امام العالم
شكرا لك سيد خلدون في ختم قمتهم بالعاصمه
النيجيريه ابو جان قاده مجموعه اكواس
اكدوا عزمهم على الابقاء على كل الخيارات
لحل ازمه النيجر بما في ذلك استخدام القوه
العسكريه دعينا في بيانهم الى تفعيل القوه
الاحتياطيه للمجموعه على الفور ياتي ذلك
بعد اعلان المجلس العسكري في النيجر عن
تشكيل حكومه يقودها الاقتصادي عالي الامين
زين وتضمه واحدا وعشرين وزيرا سالناكم على
صفحتنا على منصه اكس برايكم هل ستنفذ
مجموعه اكواس التدخل العسكري في النيجر
نعم ام لا لنرى النتائج اذا 24% صوت بنعم
على هذا السؤال بينما 76% صوتوا بلا كانت
هذه نتائج هذا السؤال الذي طرحناه عليكم
على منصتنا اكس بخصوص الاوضاع
الى باكستان حيث اعتقلت الشرطه
الباكستانيه رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان من منزله بمدينه لاهور بعد حكم بسجنه
ثلاث سنوات بتهمه بيعه هدايا منحت للدوله
بشكل غير قانوني عندما كان في منصبه ومن
جانبه طعن خان في الحكم الصدر بحقه ودعميه
الى عدم السكوت على اعتقاله وسجنه وفي
السياق المتصل قررت لجنه الانتخابات منع
خان من ممارسه العمل السياسي لمده خمس
سنوات تفاصيل اكثر عن هذا الموضوع تجدونها
في التقرير المرفق بالتعليق الاول في
الاسفل الى بريطانيا حيث تعمل الحكومه على
اخلاء عباره بيبي ستوكهولم الراسيه في
جنوب البلاد بعد العثور على بكتيريا
المسببه لداء الفيالقه في امدادات المياه
وجاء قرار الاخلاء بعد اقل من اسبوع على
نقل اول دفعه من طالبي اللجوء الى العباره
ضمن خطه الحكومه لنقلهم الى عوامات وقواعد
عسكريه بهدف تقليل تكاليف ايواءهم في
الفنادق وفي اجراء اخر قررت الحكومه
مضاعفه الغرامات المفروضه على من يقدم
عملا او يؤجر مسكنا لاي مهاجر غير نظامي
بنسبه 300
ردود فعل واسعه اعقبه قرار اخلاء العباره
نرصد لكم بعضا منها
كان ينبغي اجراء جميع عمليه الفحص ورفع
تقارير بشانها قبل السماح لاي شخص
بالاقتراب من العباره بينما يقول جوناثان
ليس العار على كل من ابتكر ونفذ وما زال
يدافع عن هذه السياسه اللا انسانيه
اصدر مرسوما بسداد ثمن الصادرات الزراعيه
الروسيه بالروبل بدلا من الدولار في اطار
التخلي عن العمله الامريكيه وستدخل
الاجراءات حيز التنفيذ في الاول من نوفمبر
المقبل بناء على المرسوم يمكن للمشترين
الاجانب فتح حسابات خاصه مقاومه بالروبل
او بعملات معينه في بنوك روسيه معتمده
لهذا الغرض واستخدامها في عمليات تسويه
الصادرات الزراعيه نتوجه الى زميلنا مذيع
ان نشر الاقتصاديه صهيب الملكاوي لنساله
عن تاثير هذا القرار اهلا بك صهيب ما
تاثير هذا القرار خصوصا بعد رفض روسيا
اتفاقيه الحبوب بالطبع كما قلنا هذا
المرسوم سيتم اقراره في الاول من المنبر
المقبل يجب على الحكومه الروسيه خلال 30
يوم قادمه ان تحدد هذه المنتجات الزراعيه
الخاضعه لهذا المرسوم الذي تم اقرار عبر
البوابه القانونيه والرسميه والذي يتضمن
اجراءات خاصه في بنود هذا هذا التصدير
اعتقد ان روسيا ستحاول اثبات الاثبات
للعالم بانها قادره على الامداد لدول
العالم بالمواد الغذائيه اللازمه وكذلك
الحبوب هذا القانون او هذا المرسوم كما
تقول الحكومه الروسيه سيحمي الدول الصديقه
وكذلك المصدرين الروس من اثر العقوب ات
وكذلك سيدخل الدول الصديقه على حد قول
الحكومه الروسيه الى سوق الاغذيه الروسي
شكرا لك كان هذا اجازه هذا الاسبوع نلقاكم
في الاسبوع المقبل
[موسيقى]